私はだいたいペアんぐとともに youtube 生活を歩み
時には提案ぐさんと直接コラボしたり霊夢の最新商品を食べたり
ペア草の手を取り合って有する生活を階段のように登ってきたわけなんですけども
そんなペヤングさんから新商品が出ました
こちらペアンで焼きそばじゃないよ hey
[拍手]
あってヤングじゃないだとペヤングですらないんですよ pr なんですよピン&
焼きそばじゃないよ激辛春雨 end
はぁん
応援とは言う応援度はややこの動画を見てる皆さんの中で敵からペアグリーンの食べた
方とれちゃいますか食べたことのある方
嫌やろいやないよもう
本当に凄いからに食べたことある人ならわかると思うんですけど本当にも辛いじゃなく
ていたいんですよベアンでじゃなくて pr って書いてあるのは気になるんだけども
すごいよねもう焼きそばじゃないのだし始めたってことだって
ドーナーこれどうな街も未知数ですねほんとに最近発売されたらしいんでもうペア具
大好きマンとしてはこれも譲れねえんでしょう食べていきましょう
うぉっ
本当にペヤングじゃねーなー
[音楽]
me
もう色でやばいんだわかる色でやばいはがレモン羽根でも貼る為ってなんかいいなぁ
なんかヘルシーぽいですね作り方は全く一緒ですね早くを入れて春雨を入れていきます
フェアん年度吠えるのは相当なんですよなんかまり戸沢村の youtube やって
来た身からすると
辛い物結構食べてきたんですよやっぱり激辛ペヤングはそんな彼らも結構上位に君臨
するんですよその上位に空気せず激辛ペアンがを模した
激辛さんでさえ釣れるものが出てるのは本当に強い
[音楽]
まじでんえ未知数なんですよ奴隷でさんが待ちましょう
おっ
相手組ズってきました正直言って僕は春雨食べたことほぼないんですよねたぶん人生で
二回目ぐらいだと思います
ポンパこれ少なくねー
少ない道はこれ max 容量ですねオペアンプと比べても何か暑くないぞ
ちょっとしか入ってないですねこれこれワンちゃん勢いで全部食えるんじゃねぇってで
も少ないしながツルツルんで入り育つ家客様の時と違ってなんか春雨は食いやすい気が
しますステージになるソースの色は
[音楽]
見たことのアメリカだな待っていろは無垢透明だった春雨に色紙レベルを制されいう
ことってこんなに色かあるんか
[音楽]
思い出しちゃったこれでややメーラご覧ください
もうちらゲラペヤングさんよりの新商品
やんぬ
激辛口ヤングじゃないよ駅から深草目遠藤ん
いい
まだ
あーやばいも思い出しちゃうこれで本土美味しいですけどまずでからくてぃてぃんだ
レジがしっかりと新商品の味を伝えるのもユーチューバーの仕事を輸入していき
ましょう
もう行けそうだった兄で全部食っちゃいますね誰か
ああああああああ
yeah
[音楽]
ブーバー新眠いぞ
初心者溺愛ですよだけねーがーアルファ
さああああ
[音楽]
いもうこの発汗量で感じだもんじゃんけど本当にアド僕から
nde ああああ
[音楽]
20 a
ああ
[音楽]
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
おおおおお
はっはっはうわぁ
me
teame
car
uh